hey and I did want an update before we
start news real quick what happened
Chris Wilding and his date with Andy
Cohen alright let's go for a drink
you sure yeah alright we're gonna have a
drink yeah love is in the air did they
have a date here's where it is only our
DMing on instagram i proposed this week
for the drink
and he said this week was very hectic
for him so perhaps next week no he's not
saying no and I ran into him in the
hallway here and we'd had an elevator
ride down and I got to thank him for
everything right
he was sweet to you he was very very
sweet you're looking for something real
you will find it and this guy was not
the right guy I want you to try to
remember that and move on okay you were
so [ __ ] hot any flirty DMS or is it
all business it's very business have you
guys shared any dick pics yet no well
Benji had a great idea he goes your
first message to him should just be a
dick pic yeah get out of the friend zone
right away and you have seven inches you
claim although I heard in the office
they're claiming you don't have seven
inches that you lied yeah well how the
[ __ ] does anyone in the office know what
I'm getting a chance and guys are
walking around with rulers and they're
going this is what you have this is
what's in your pants like I can't have
seven inches do you have seven inches I
will cop to this I rounded up a little
bit all right
but we are completely in the
neighborhood of seven acres I round up
to I'm three inches and I round up to
six right but imagine if someone said to
you oh you're never at your six inches
it's so insulting I know that one guy in
there is needling him pretty badly yeah
and you know they're saying it's a
physical improbability he gave me this
realization to fit it would have to be
that big that seven inches I told you
six point five I'm surprised you don't
topple over your guy you know when I
told Andy seven inches he didn't flinch
won't you show it to Gary and then he
can verify I have to be hard I actually
like you I would measure you if you
wanted to get barred go to bathroom
measure you get you some hard and like
Gary measure you I don't know if I mean
this is important to res no offense to
Gary you guys you're an attractive guy I
don't know if I could get hard in that
situation wonderful
it hard then call Marion but how am I
gonna get hard work look at Fred that's
what I do
but listen when I'm engines when I'm
measuring I met my hardest like I'm
almost ready to come so you better bring
[ __ ] goggles intelligent here in the
middle of measuring him and he comes he
waits until that point and he starts
measuring all right anyway so the update
is Chris Wilding and Andy Cohen have not
gone on in the day and he was busy this
week possibly next week do you think
Andy's blowing you off or do you think
he's gonna have a drink with you I think
if we keep talking about it the drink
will happened but if like we don't
mention it again I think it'll go away
yeah which by the way Andy it's fine
Benji thinks Andy was flirting with him
I'm not kidding well is Benji a bird
what if Benji ends up Benji gets the
drink over me I'm gonna be very upset
I'm really well being I think Benji
would be open to it too is Benji a top
or a bottom
I think he's whatever you want I feel
your fancy
[Laughter]